I was nine years old when I first started
playing organized hockey, and it was just
something that became a passion.
It was a case where I was playing football
in high school, but our games were Saturday
afternoons.
I would play football in the afternoon, and
then go play hockey at night.
Because my high school didn't have a hockey
team, I started the hockey team there my senior
year also.
So when I came to Hillsdale, my first year,
all I wanted was to get good grades because,
as I said, my dream was to transfer from Hillsdale
so I could find a school to play hockey.
Because I'd been Dean's list my freshman year,
I decided, well, I'm going to see if I can
get a group together.
I put up posters around the campus, asking
for any students who might be interested in
forming a hockey club.
Out of the blue, we had I think 10 or 12 skaters,
some better than the others.
That first ragtag team, we used to skate on
Baw Beese Lake or the arb pond.
When we could get some money together, we
would go up to the University of Michigan.
Usually at midnight or 1:00 was the only time
that we could get the ice.
We'd pile into three or four cars and drive
up there and then skate.
That first year we had four games, and then
the last game of the season we drove down
to Columbus, Ohio to play the Ohio State JV's
and we beat them 17 to nothing.
It was a great way to end our first season.
I think the thing that really brought success
to the program, they built an arena in Jackson.
In '68, '69, the last game of the season was
the Purdue game and it was standing room only.
You couldn't find a place even to walk.
Here's little Hillsdale College playing Purdue
University.
We were losing two to nothing after the first
period and we beat Purdue 14 to two.
When the students went back to campus there
was such a buzz about the hockey team that
that's when they put together a petition and
they petitioned the Board of Trustees to make
it a varsity sport and the board approved
it.
I coached from 1962 to 1963 and when I came
back I coached from 1966 to 1974.
I never planned to coach.
I'd wanted to skate.
I wound up coaching and really through books
and other things had to teach myself.
Jeff called and left a message on my phone,
he said, "I have to tell you, you know, you're
being inducted into the athletic hall of fame
at Hillsdale College."
He told me that a lot of the younger players,
they'd sent a letter off to the director of
athletics.
It was humbling.
I was very shocked, very surprised, but obviously
to have it happen now was just totally amazing
and as I said, extremely humbling.